uh now some news coming into us an
emergency meeting of SNP politicians has
been taking place within the last hour
it follows the arrest of the party's
Treasurer Colin Beatty it's all in
connection with the ongoing
investigation into the party's funding
and finances it comes two weeks after
the former SMP chief executive Peter
Murrell Nicholas sturgeon's husband was
also arrested we'd go live to Hollywood
and find out more our Scotland
correspondent Connor Gillis is standing
by Colin what more details can you give
us about this emergency meeting
yeah another very very difficult day for
the SMP that arrest this morning of its
Treasurer Colin Beatty that of course
comes in the wake of the 11 hour
detention that Peter model faced the
former Chief Executive who was in power
within the SNP for decades so these two
high-profile arrests have emerged over
the course of the last couple of weeks
the latest today and yes that emergency
meeting of SMP msps here in Edinburgh at
the Scottish Parliament meeting
face-to-face to question the first
Minister their new leader Hamza Yusuf as
part of what has been a very difficult
time they I'm told uh were facing
questions we're answering a number of
questions the first Minister was
tackling those head on and the moot
within that room was fairly downbeat but
also resolutely by behind what the first
Minister has been saying clearly this is
a live police investigation and that has
been the line coming from Scotland's
first Minister today but let's remember
this is an investigation that centers on
600 000 pounds that was raised for the
cause of his second Scottish
independence vote and there have been
questions around the finances and the
fundraising of the SMP and that has been
a long-running police investigation that
culminated in that arrest and later
release of Peter Model A number of weeks
ago and then the arrest today of
Scotland's the smps uh Treasurer as well
let's remember I'm just keeping an eye
out because politicians are making their
way into the chamber here there is due
to be a high profile uh announcement by
the first minute so let's hear uh dip
into what the labor leader Anna star
wars in the political party that is
mired in Scandal admired in corruption
engulfed in this crisis and at a time
when our country needs true leadership
it needs a government focused on the
twin crisis of the NHS crisis and the
cost of living crisis they are too busy
talking to themselves about themselves
and I think in three short weeks we
already have a lame duck first Minister
and a lame duck government it was a gift
for labor though look we have the rise
to the opportunity I think people across
this country are crying out for change
we now have to demonstrate how we will
be that change you're live on Skype news
at the moment Anna star war what do you
make of the signals that this sends out
to the public at the moment well I think
it's clear for everyone to see that the
culture of command and control we've
seen for 16 years the culture of secrecy
and cover-up is now engulfing not just
the SNP but as in golf government for 16
years with devastating consequences and
a time when our country needs that New
Hope for the future it needs new Energy
new ideas in New Vision that's not going
to come from the SMP it's not going to
come from Hamza Yusuf after three weeks
we already have a lame duck first
Minister and lame government and that's
not good for our country okay thanks
very much indeed that is the labor
leader Anna sarwar there live on Sky
News now they are entering the Hollywood
chamber here because in just a matter of
moments Scotland's new first Minister
Hamza Yusuf is going to be delivering
his first major parliamentary speech
where he will uh be laying out his
priorities and his policies for the
years ahead clearly that has been
derailed by this major announcement
today from police Scotland and just a
short while ago we heard from Mr Youssef
himself let's take a listen
have you suspended him from the party
I've said already then people are
innocent until proven guilty in that
supremacist will you take him off the
public order Timothy in the meantime
look again I'll consider that I'll have
to speak to Colombia team understanding
as he's still in the police station
being questioned uh clearly when he's uh
off that at least have a wonderful and
not about the live police investigation
we can't speak about the detail of that
a bit clearly there are pertinent issues
around his role public audit committee
and his role of course as the National
Treasure are you surprised that he's
been arrested uh well yes of course I'm
surprised with one of my colleagues has
been arrested but uh you know it's a
very serious matter indeed
does this starting to derail what you're
talking about here in Parliament this
afternoon it certainly is not helpful uh
of course I wanted to I've all I'm still
determined of course to articulate what
my vision is as a new leader and a fresh
start for the government as well still
do that of course at uh 20 minutes uh
past two and I hope that we can move on
to speak about those issues
now unlike the hive of police activity
that we witnessed just a number of weeks
ago at the home of Peter Murrell and
Nicola sturgeon Scotland's former first
Minister that tent that was erected in
the front lawn uh the masses of
detectives that set foot on that
property that has not been the case at
the home of Colin B2 who is a serving
member of the parliament that I am in
just now no police activity at his
property no police activity that we
could see at his constituency office as
well let's remember this is uh live
pictures we're viewing just now of msps
taking their seats within the chamber
here ahead of that statement from the
first Minister amid this backdrop of a
very testing time and a live police
investigation
okay well when the first Minister gets
to his feet in Holly Rood we will bring
it to you live here on Sky News Conor
for the moment thank you